is a British Egyptian democracy activist
and writer who's been in prison for
Egypt for most of the last decade in
December last year he was jailed for a
further five years for supposedly
spreading fake news he's been on Hunger
Strike but from today he says he will
refuse to drink water as well the
foreign secretary James cleverley says
the government is working tirelessly for
his release but his family's warning
that he could die even during Rishi
sunak's visit to the country for comp
and now we can reveal on this program
that prime minister Rishi sunak has
written to his sister's Sana saying that
he is committed to seeking Allah's
release Santa will be flying to Egypt
later today but she joins us now at live
on the program thank you so much for
being with us it must be you know very
distressing time for you and your family
when was the last time you heard from
your brother it was um on the on the
31st so like
a week ago through a letter
uh where he told us that he will
escalate his hunger strike last time
anyone saw him was my mom on on the 16th
we only have a visit once a month
it's behind the glass Shield
um and so the next visits will be on the
16th which would be too late I think
and talked he's been on hunger strike
for before eating just 100 calories a
day for seven months I mean I can't
imagine what that must have been like
yeah he's uh he's been on this partial
hunger strike for over 200 days
I last saw him in August that's the last
time I visited Egypt and he already
looked very very frail he already looked
to me very scary
um his eyes were sunken he he looked
strange
um his mind was still alert and he was
still like my brother but
I I was reading online about what
happens when you're dehydrated what
happens to a body when
you stop water and it's it's already
very scary for a normal body and Alice
but he's not normal he's very free
already
I just want to also remind that he is
he's putting his body on on the line not
because he wants to die but because he
wants to live and he wants his life back
and he's really tired of this
Alia has a a 10 year old boy and I spent
nine of the past nine in the past nine
years in prison he he hasn't had time
with his kid
we having a look at um
him
you two together on the screen behind us
now very different yeah looking brother
I'm sure at this point oh he doesn't
look like that at all we were in South
Africa having a safari back then
um he has been in prison as you say for
the best part of a decade and he was
sentenced to five years imprisonment in
Egypt last December can you just explain
to us why he's in prison
technically for like
Facebook posts the only piece of
evidence there's a Facebook post that he
shared not one that you wrote but one
that you shared about a human rights
violation in Egyptian prison
um but Allah is also and it is like Ali
is a writer and he was a prominent uh
pro-democracy secular activist figure
back in 2011 where there when there was
an uprising in Egypt and so he's kind of
used to set an example for others
um and that's why I think the attack is
so vicious on him that's why they're
keen on keeping him in prison and
whenever he finishes the sentence they
put him on a new one
was saying his boy there as well
the rare occasions that he could see his
dad
has not seen his father for over a year
now
because Khaled is um he's non-verbal he
does not communicate he's on the
Spectrum
and for the past three years Alex visits
are behind the glass shield with phone
speakers we've explained many times to
the Egyptian authorities that his son
cannot communicate in that form
at first they would make like exceptions
for the kid and then they decided not to
um so that's I'm I'm stressing on these
things because Alias denied many of his
basic rights even by their laws which
are wrong his charge on a misdemeanor
but they treat him as if he's like a a
terrorist or a grand Criminal
and of course this is happening in Egypt
which is preparing to host world leaders
for the cop climate change Summit you've
received a letter from Russia sutnik the
UK prime minister what does it say
um I was glad to see that he he said
we received it yesterday that he said
that he he feels our
our families paid that is he understands
this painful time for the family
um
I
it's good that we have a commitment from
the prime minister's office but what
worried me is that he said that we will
get information after the conference
I I feel like
the Prime Minister needs to understand
the urgency after the conferencing could
be too late
I I know it's not the prime minister's
uh
mistake but
the foreign office the embassy and
we've we've been we've been they've been
working on this for for very long and I
feel like they've been setting the prime
minister to fail in this trip it will be
his first trip
and so it's it's a challenge but I I
hope I hope prime minister Rishi Sonic
understands the urgency and I know he
can do it if he has his mind to it and
if he shows the rest of the entities and
the government that this is a priority
and I know it's really hard to to talk
about but just to I guess make it really
Crystal Clear what you're saying is
you're saying that it could be too late
because your brother is about to stop
drinking water and he could he could die
while cop is going on is that what you
what you mean yeah I'm worried that he
could die while the conference is
happening and while the prime minister
is over there
I'm I'm also we don't have a way to know
so I I would urge
the Prime Minister and the British
government to be the ones responsible
for getting us Proof of Life
and consider access is a right to the
British government we as family
our first visit is on the 16th my mom
will go every other day to the prison
and try to to ask but
they can ignore her so
while there is a British delegation that
will be over over there an official
delegation that will be engaging with
the Egyptian authorities
the assumptions need to show some
respect to the prime minister's visit
and
get Consular access to the Embassy or
get us a proof of life until it is
resolved it's it's very urgent and
as Naomi Klein put it in in an article
she said if
if we can't save this man if we can't
get him out of prison and what hope do
we have for saving our planet this this
case has got so much International
attention and solidarity
and all of these world leaders are going
including prime minister Rishi sunak
this is a very they will make big
pledges about the planet that we're not
sure if they will work or not according
to them so the previous conferences but
this is a very simple thing that you can
make happen and it's a good thing and
it's just it's not that hard
and in the letter where she said like
does say that he is going to raise this
directly with the Egyptian president is
that something that gives you some
optimism I understand what you're saying
about time frame of course it gives me
optimism that his Central Family a
letter and that he understands the
urgency but just raising it I don't know
like it has been raised before and I
feel like
politicians understand when when they
raise things out of lip service or when
they actually care
um and and I'm sure I'm sure number 10
understands how to do how to do it
properly so I'm I'm hoping it won't be
just lip service I'm hoping it will be
we really care
um Britain has a very strong
relationship with Egypt and and so it's
easy it's your friend you can
negotiate something with them okay
okay thank you so much for being on the
program I know how difficult it has been
for you to to talk about this that we
you know we admire your bravery incoming
on and being a voice of your brother
thank you thank you thank you